right we are here we're celebrating lucy
and desi you have being the ricardo's
coming out all this celebration for your
folks what is what does it feel like
it feels amazing it's raining lucy and
desi right now it feels it just feels
great you know the tcm podcast the we
found the old let's talk to lucy radio
shows and the picture and then they want
and and only the radio shows came from
us
i found those i wanted to put them out
everything else
came to us and i just think it was the
right time you know this it's it's a
it's a time to celebrate unconditional
love and it's a time to explore
relationships
deeper
and um and and there are a very good uh
suspects to to to use for that hi there
he said let's go see a ball and i said
oh man that's a hunk of woman i was
madly in love with dessie i've never
felt that way about anyone before
no one wanted him to play my husband
because he was cuban and they wanted a
real american couple the only reason i
love lucy exists is because they wanted
to be together what do you wish for the
continued legacy how would you like them
remembered
exactly the way we're doing it right now
how can it get better than this i mean
70 years after their show went off the
air and hundreds of years after they
were born
to suddenly
be
i don't want to say reinvented they're
not reinvented but rediscovered and
reappreciated and and
used to teach and to find
a better way to live our life
beautifully said and exactly that is
happening i watch this film today and
i'll tell you one thing i know about
them they worked their buns off to make
it in this business and it is inspiring
it's truly beautiful yeah well that's
one good way to look at it you know you
got to look at that's what they did they
chose to go head on into that and um the
relationship didn't last as long as
their children might have wanted it to
but in reality
their love for each other lasted forever
so what do you you don't get better than
that really you know talk a little bit
about the tapes and the different
footage and the different um sounds that
have been coming to you
what's it like reliving these moments
through your parents words got to be
incredible
yeah you know the older you get i mean i
may have heard these things before but
the older we get the older your children
get the longer you're married the more
you understand
what people go through in order to try
to stay together and have relationships
and raise their children and
stay
you know working in this business and
it's not easy and and they did it really
well
and still didn't really succeed on some
levels but it's it's a great thing to
look at and say well would i have would
i have made those choices that would i
have done it differently would i have
succeeded you don't you never know i
need you to help me save my marriage
how many times i gotta explain where i
was and what i was doing you gotta
explain are you being funny i'm lucille
ball when i'm being funny you'll know
nicole javier jk simmons all oscar noms
you're a producer on this thing how i
mean you must be over the move we're
very proud they were amazing cast
and uh they they did a brilliant job
just absolutely beautiful what they were
given to do i think they brought their a
game plus and i'm so happy for all three
of them